anything's possible
the futures
Unwritten and just like that the future
seems to be written we like you
like it Sarah Jessica Parker and Kristen
Davis responded filming season two of
and just like that the Sex and the City
Revival series check out the stars as
they hit the streets of New York City in
as expected some seriously fashionable
looks it was just magical SJP keeping
Carrie casual in a green jumpsuit and
Kristen well this Chic number with a
statement Beau feels so Charlotte Sarah
also shared this snap on Instagram and
it's all about the details look at those
Dior heels oh my God
I have died and gone to real estate
Heaven yeah looks like Harry's bringing
back some Chic Footwear from the First
Sex in the City movie hello
I live here and we gotta talk about that
pigeon purse anyone else getting
Whiplash from season two of the OG
series when big gave Carrie a bedazzled
Judith Lieber Swan bag it was just wrong
it was wrong I didn't know what to say
except I love you and while the fashion
we're seeing here is making us eager for
season two no official release date has
been announced just yet because I think
Carrie Bradshaw would be just so greedy
to have to share her feelings and
thoughts but here's what we do know some
familiar faces are back for more okay do
me a favor stop talking and just breathe
Sato Ramirez AKA Che Diaz is back they
posted a pic of a script to Instagram so
we'll have to wait and see where things
land between them and Miranda Jay got a
big TV thing and they asked me to go
with them and I mean I couldn't pass it
up and after lots of speculation it
seems John Corbett set to return as a
fan favorite Aiden wish that I could be
your girlfriend again
well selfishly I like to win my
characters like to win
ET recently spoke with SJP and while
teasing season two she all but confirmed
Aiden is back
to about resilience and rebound and
laughter and finding laughter more
easily for people who might have
experienced grief and more of our new
cast members who we love and more Aiden
could be could be well you know I mean I
can't be I can't be like cryptic about
it
I'm very excited
[Music]
foreign